to understand climate change think of
the game Tetris for eons earthís played
a version of this game with blocks of
carbon they enter the atmosphere as
carbon dioxide gas from volcanoes
decaying plant matter breathing
creatures and the surface of the sea and
they leave the atmosphere when they're
used by plants during photosynthesis
absorbed back into the ocean or store it
in soil and sediment this game of Tetris
is called the carbon cycle and it's the
engine of life on Earth what's the
connection to climate well when that
carbon dioxide is in the air waiting to
be reabsorbed it traps a portion of the
sun's heat which would otherwise escape
to space
that's why carbon dioxide is called a
greenhouse gas it creates a blanket of
warmth known as the greenhouse effect
that keeps our earth from freezing like
Mars the more carbon dioxide blocks hang
out in the atmosphere waiting to be
cleared the warmer earth becomes though
the amount of carbon in the atmosphere
has varied through ice ages and asteroid
impacts over the past eight thousand
years the stable climate we know took
shape allowing human civilization to
thrive but about 200 years ago we began
digging up that old carbon that had been
stored in the soil these fossil fuels
coal oil and natural gas are made from
the Buried remains of plants and animals
that died long before humans evolved the
energy stored inside them was able to
power our factories cars and power
plants but burning these fuels also
injected new carbon blocks into Earth's
tetris game at the same time we cleared
forests for agriculture reducing the
Earth's ability to remove the blocks and
since 1750 the amount of carbon in the
atmosphere has increased by 40% and
shows no sign of slowing just like in
Tetris the more blocks pile up the
harder it becomes to restore stability
the extra carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere accelerates the greenhouse
effect by trapping more heat near the
surface and causing polar icecaps to
melt and the more they melt the less
sunlight they're able to reflect making
the oceans warm even faster
sea levels rise coastal populations are
threatened with flooding natural
ecosystems are disrupted and the
other becomes more extreme over time
climate change may affect different
people in places in different ways but
ultimately it's a game that we're all
stuck playing and unlike in tetris we
won't get a chance to start over and try
again
Oh